come on in meet my amiibo hi I'm Josh's
digby amiibo and I Isabelle isn't it
great to invite friends over whenever
you want yep and you can do just that
with amiibo figures like us and the
latest Animal Crossing games in the
Animal Crossing happy home designer game
all you have to do is tap the Animal
Crossing series amiibo figure or card to
your new Nintendo 3ds or new Nintendo
3ds XL if you have any other kind of
system in the Nintendo 3ds family you
can use the Nintendo 3ds nfcu
reader-writer accessory then that
villager will show up in your game and
you can even design a house for them it
feels great to bring the whole family
together and use those same an EVO on
the Wii U console with the Animal
Crossing amiibo festival game it's a
digital board game that brings your
meebo to life plus am evil that are
compatible with both games can also
carry your data over for an animal
crossing happy home designer to see the
house you design on the big screen and
check this out there's a free update
coming for the game animal crossing new
leaf which is crazy cuz it already has a
whole town to explore and you're the
mayor the new update will add in fun new
stuff to move pata Bulls bow
perfect because there are 50 new amigo
cards coming to the series wait you
don't have animal crossing you leave
don't worry the game is out right now at
a great price this is a great party
there's so much for amiibo to do my head
is spinning your whole body spinning gum
baby